I am surprised how much of Palmyra has
survived most of the ruins are just as
breathtaking as they were a year ago
when the ancient city was occupied by
the is terrorist militia traveling as an
embedded reporter with the Russian
military I am one of the first
journalist to enter Palmyra after its
recapture by Syrian government forces
backed by the Russians Palmyra is the
first stop of the Russian organized
strip for journalists its occupation by
is was followed with concern around the
world and it's still off limits for the
public because the is has apparently
mind every second square meter we are
invited to witness Russian bomb disposal
experts at work on their media friendly
mission
till about nine it is gorgeous these
boys are risking their lives so that
others can come here safely and see what
was achieved a thousand years ago
shalita not reproduce the soldiers
ensure the controlled explosions take
place at a safe distance from the ruins
in four hours we see a dozen mine
surrender at harmless Syrian
archaeologists have high hopes of the
operation madine Ted Marty Pattin here
is a world heritage site the restoration
must be carried out carefully and that
will most certainly be a long process
modular what Gideon it's just a short
hop from the ancient ruins to the
northern town of Palmyra but we are
taken there in the armored vehicle al
meera may be back in government forces
hands but fighting continues nearby